[Müzik]
Herkese merhaba hepiniz hoşgeldiniz ben
Robin Yayla tasarımcı ve ilistir
atıyorum gezip gördüğüm yerlerdeki
yapıların üzerlerine yaptığım
illüstrasyonlar layan resimlerle onları
başka nesneleri dönüştürüyorum görmeye
alışkın olduğumuz şekillerde değil
bambaşka nesneler olarak İnsanların
karşısına çıkarmaya amaçlıyorum birebir
maskeleme yapıyorum ama ben önce Hikayem
biraz başa sarmak istiyorum Geçmişte
yaşadığım bazı olayların şu anda
yaptığım işle bağlantısını size anlatmak
istiyorum hayatımdaki bazı kırılma
anlarından dönüm noktalarından bahsetmek
Umarım ilham verici bir konuşma Olur
tabii ki herkes gibi ben de çocukken
başladım resim çizmeye kalem ve kağıt
benim en yakın dostlarım da bunun nedeni
takım sporlarını olan yeteneksizliğin de
ve sınıf arkadaşlarımı tarafından
basketbol veya futbol oynayacağız zaman
pek fazla tercih edilme Bende bu nedenle
kalem ve kağıt benim en iyi dostlarım
olmuştu
duygularımı düşüncelerimi hep onlar
yoluyla ifade etmeye başlamıştım
ders defterlerin bir yerden sonra artık
resim defterimi haline dönmüştür hocalar
bu konuda çok şikayetçi lerde ve her
derste hocalardan azar işitiyorum Hatta
bir keresinde
kocamın anlattığı bir konuyu yazarak not
almak yerine
anlattı her şeyi resmederek defterime
not almıştım ve bu nedenle
sınıftan atılmış tım şimdi o günden
bugüne bakınca Aslında yaptığım işte en
ufak bir değişiklik yok En ufak bir fark
yok
zaman nasıl kendimi resim çizerek
çizimler yaparak ifade ediyorsam aynı
şekilde kendime en iyi ifade etme şeklim
bu resim çizmek ve üretime Tutkusu
sonucunda
üniversitede endüstri ürünleri tasarımı
bölümü bölümünü
bölümü kazandığından itibaren en büyük
hedefim mezun olduktan sonra oranın
tasarım ve sanat büyük ünlü yerinde
öğrenme yani Konfor alanından çıkıp
ve bunun için önemli bir fırsat vardı bu
fırsatta bir tasarım yarışması ulusal
bir tasarım yarışması ve birinci yüksek
lisans Yurtdışı Eğitim bursu
veriyorlardı Ben de tabii ki bu fırsatı
değerlendirmek üzere bir Tasarım yaptım
yarışmaya katıldım ilk denememde 4'lük
ödülünü aldım Türkiye genelinde hedefim
için yeterli değildi Çok üzülmüştüm ama
bir sonraki sene
verdim 3. oldum halen hedefim için
yetmiyordu bu
kalmıştı mezunu olmadan önce katılmam
gereken son bir yarışma Çünkü mezun
olduktan sonra bu şansı artık
Ve bu son şansı da kullanmak üzere yine
bir ürün Tasarım yaptım ve yarışmaya
katıldım çok umutluydum kazanacağım için
Bu kez de ikincilik ödülü aldım ve
bayağı Moralim bozuldu çünkü asıl
hedefin birincilikle ve yurtdışı bursunu
kazanmaktı ve daha sonradan öğrendim ki
1. olan arkadaş bu bursu kullanamayacak
ve burs otomatikman bana geçti
Evet ben burada çok şanslıyım ama benim
burada vurgulamak istediğim nokta o
şansı nasıl kendimin yarattığı ydı ben
ilk denemede başarısız olduğunda pes
etseydim hedefine ulaşamayacak kimya 2.
denemede Oturduğun yerden hedefine
ulaşmak isteseydim başarısız olacaktım
hedefini ulaşamayacak tım ve ben şansımı
sonuna kadar zorlamaya karar verdim ya
sonunda da şansımın Yaver gitmesi ile bu
hedefine ulaştı
sonrasında İtalya maceram başladı Orada
yüksek lisans eğitimi aldım Bu sürede
Sanat ve tasarım anlamında kendimi çok
geliştirdim Ama bu kendimi geliştirmenin
en önemli en önemli nedenlerinden birisi
de okul değil Okul dışında
yaşadıklarımızı Çünkü ben Türkiye'den
oraya gittim tüketici Konfor alanı mı
bıraktım Bir bilinmezliğe doğru gittim
hiç bir kişiyi tanımıyordum orada dilini
bilmiyorum
mümkün olduğunca gezip yeni yerler
görmeye başladım Çünkü
Konfor alanından çıkınca Özgün'ü
özgüvenim in yerine geldiğini fark ettim
daha çok şey öğrendiğini fark ettim ve
sırt çantamı alıp her fırsat
şehir farklı şehirlere farklı
kimi zaman tek başıma Kimi zaman bir
arkadaşımdan bir gün karar verdim
iskandil abi gitmek üzere yola koyuldum
Norveç'te Kuzey bölgede bir vakit
geçirdim Çünkü oranın doğası beni
inanılmaz cezbediyor
kimi zaman da oluyor hiç tanımadığım
insanlarla aynı Booster odasını
paylaştım onların hikayelerini dinledim
onlardan çok şey öğrendim onlarla
beraber
[Müzik]
onlarla beraber
yeni yerler keşfettik ya bugün
özgüvenimi inanılmaz arttırdı ve Daha
sonrasında da
ben o dönemde kendi tarzımı oluşturmaya
çalışıyorum Kendi tasarım dilimi
olmuştum
Evet küçüklükten beri bir resim çizme
merakım vardı resim çiziyordum kendin
bunu yolla ifade ediyordum ama temiz bir
tarzım oluşmamış the ve benim artık
ikinci bir Tutkun vardı birincisi resim
çizmek illüstrasyonlar yapmak İkincisi
de gezip yeni yerler keşfetmek Oraların
karakteristik yapılarına ya da hiç
Keşfedilmemiş yerlerini görüp oraları
keşfetmek ti Tek bildiğim bir şey vardı
Kendi çizim tarzım değil
o da şuydu
gördüğüm şeyin hiçbir zaman aynısını
resmi etmezdim bu bana hep sıkıcı
gelmişti ya gördüğüm şeyin bir yerini
deforme eder onu kendi filtreni den
geçirip resmeder
ya da karakteristik bir özelliğini
abartarak karikatürize ederek resme
derdim bu da o aydınlanmanın olduğu
yerde ben bu iki Fikri bu iki tutkuyu
resim çizme ve gezip yeni yerler görmek
keşfetme tuttu mu bir araya getirmeye
karar verdim de kendi dilimi oluşturmaya
kadar Bunu da nasıl yaptım gördün
yerlerdeki duayı tarihi oradaki
nesneleri sokaktaki herhangi bir şeyi
yeniden yorumlamaya kadar
[Müzik]
Onlara hep yeni kimlikler kazandırmaya
amaçladım
onları biz görmeye alışkın olduğumuz
şekilde değildi bambaşka fonlarda
insanları karşıma çıkınca insan
insanların yüzündeki o tebessümünü ve
Benim de en temel amacım bu çalışmaları
yaparken
insanların yüzünü güldürmek insanları
yüzünde tebessüm oluştum
dönemler geçiriyoruz gerek pendimi gerek
ekonomik sıkıntılar gel neden sosyal
medyaya bu çalışmalarından
insanların yüzünü bineli güldürmek
olaylara farklı perspektiflerden
bakmalarını biraz olsun sağlamak için
çalışmalar yapmaya
[Müzik]
kemanın olduğunu duydum Aslı benim
yaptığım işle ne kadar paralel bir iş ol
bir tanem olduğunu fark ettim
yapılır ve doğayı düzenleme yaptı
Müslümanların binevi mas geliyorum
onlara Ben başlıklar kazandırın
askerimi işlemini nasıl yaptığından
biraz bahsetmek istiyorum Nasıl bir yol
izleyeyim
çalışmam
Öncelikle nasıl bir yol izlediğimden
bahsetmek istiyorum ben bu yapıyor
baktığım andan itibaren artık bu Yapı
benim için bir mimari yapı benim için
tamamen bir grafik lekeye dönüşüyor
zihinde onu en soyut haline indir
diyorum yani bu da ne demektir
onları ne giydin üstüne bakınca orası
kesilmiş bir kilo olarak görüyorum
ile ilgili bir fikriniz yok ne olabilir
Ne olarak tanımlanabilir
bunun hikayesini anlatmak istiyorum önce
daha sonra çalışmam göstermek
hava çok sıcaktı ve
bir şeyler içmeye karar Ben de her zaman
oldu gidip
nasıl yapılır inceliyordum Nasıl yeniden
yorumlayabilir İmge düşünüyorum
içerim limonata portakal
kelime ile benim dinimde tüpü bir ara
ortaya Bu görüntü çıktı
bu çalışma benim o anki duygu ve
düşüncelerini psikolojik ruh halimin
Aslında benim perspektifinden dışavurum
uydu
Galata Kulesi
Evet genelde spontane fikirler biliyorum
Ancak kimi zaman da gündemdeki olaylar
ile alakalı da çalışmalar
olaylara kendi
göndermeler yapmak çok
o dönemde sphex günden değdi uzaya
insanların araç yollamış da
düşündüm
bu araç Türkiye'de nasıl saydı
Ve ben bunu resmi etseydim nasıl bir
manzara ile karşılaşır diye
Ben çalışmalarımı yaparken
hep
yurtdışındaki yapılarla ilgili
çalışmalar yapıyorum Avrupa'daki
İtalya'daki Ama daha sonra
İtalya'daki bazı arkadaşlarımın İstanbul
ve Türkiye ile olan bakış açılarını
gördükten sonra Burayı çok yanlış
tanımalarını Tanıdıklarını Şehit
olduktan sonra İstanbul ve Türkiye'nin
diğer güzelliklerini de onlara sunma
ihtiyacı hissettim ve buna da nereden
başladı Tabii ki
Dünyada eşi benzeri olmayan bir
oranın kimliği haline gelen balonları
Nasıl yeniden yolundayım insanları
karşısına çıkarabilirim
ve bu
düşünce sonucunda gözümde bir
kahramanlarımızdan
Oburix gelir bazen
keşke maskelerinizi olmasaydı daha
üzerinizdeki tepesi mi daha ne
istediğim manzara
amacım
insanların yüzünü güldürmek olan birisi
için bu mal
bu manzarayı hepiniz biliyorsunuz her
İstanbul diyor gerçekten çok güzel bir
manzara müsilaj problemi çok sık
karşımıza çıkıyor ve hepimizi derinden
üzüyor genelde Ben yaptığım çalışmalarla
insanların yüzünü güldürmek istiyorum
onlar da tebessüm Yalan atmayalım
kimi zaman geliyor dünden
onu kendi perspektifinden insanlara
sunmak istiyorum çünkü
onu daha çarpıcı hale getirmek istiyorum
ki insanların aklına kazınsın Evet
herkes sosyal medyada yazdığı ettiği
paylaşımlar yaptığı bu konuya değindi
ben de düşündüm
konuya nasıl Ben
İnsanların karşısına çıkar insanların
aklında yer eder Buna da nereden
başladım silajın kaynağından ışık
kaynağı nedir Onu araştırın ve daha
sonradan silajın kaynağını öyle bir
resmetmek insanların aklına bu şekilde
kazanmasını bu kişi sembolik bir eve
hepimiz tanıyorsun
geçen sene
pandemi ilk patladığında ben Milano
daydım beni zorda vakalar yeni yeni
yükselmeye başlamıştı ve ben de ok
telaşı yedim tabii ki apar topar
valizimi hazırladım ve bir gece yarısı
apar topar İstanbul'a geldim
Daha sonra İstanbul'a ben geldikten
hemen sonra kapılar oradaki projelerim
oradaki işlerimi iptal oldu
hepimiz için çok bir süre var hepimiz
şimdi belirsizlik
Çünkü daha önceden böyle bir deneyimimiz
karşılık veririz bilmiyorduk
Bu konuyla alakalı bir çalışma insan
ben buraya geldikten sonra tabii ki
İstanbul'da Türk
endişeyi korkuyu gördüm
nasıl bir çalışma yapabilirim ki
insanların evine girelim o çalışma ile
beraber o çalışma ile İnsanların Yüzünü
güldürürüm her zaman mesaj verirken
diye düşündüm
düşünme
nedir iki Yakayı bir araya getirirler
insanları bir araya getirmek için olan
bir unsurdur Köprüler Ama ben bu dönemde
köprülerin bu ana özelliğini yerine
getirmemesi gerektiğini vurgulamak
istedim bizim sağlığımız için Ve bunu
yaparken yine zihnimde
ensoy
[Müzik]
kuponlardan
iki insanı gördüm
birbirlerine el sallayarak bir
süreliğine o iki insanın bir araya
gelmemesi gerektiğini vurguladım Aslında
bu iki insan biziz
bu bizi temsil ediyor ve Umarım dünya
Eski haline geri döner iki insan bir
araya gelir ve ben de bunu resmederim
Türkiye'nin diğer güzelliklerinden
asostaki tarihi yapılardan esinlendim
onları yeniden yorumlamak istedim
izlediğim filmler izlediğim diziler
okuduğum kitaplar beni her zaman çok
Beste der onlardan çok şey aldım
çalışmalarıma da onları uyarlamak
istedim Nasıl yeniden yorumlayıp
istediğim filmden diziden en can alıcı
sahne kendi çalışmalarına
uyandırabilirim
satranç dizisinin en çok
yeniden
Galata köprüsünün önceki haline hepiniz
hatırlıyorsunuz değil mi müziğin eksik
olmadığı kalabalığın eksik olmadığı
bu pandemi döneminde Tabii ki sağlığımız
için
Galata Kulesi eski halinde değil müzik
yok kalabalık değil ve bu beni çok
rahatsız etmişti
nasıl bir çalışma yapabilirim ki
Galata Kulesi'ne binevi kendi açımdan
eski haline döndürebilirim diye
düşünürken yine köprücüğe
yine kendi perspektifinden baktım o
gitar perdelerini gördüm
size gördünüz mü gitar perdelerini
kendi perspektifinden Galata Kulesi'ni
nasıl eski haline döndürebilirim diye
düşündüm mi böyle bir çalışma yapmak
şimdi
yaptığım çalışmaların en büyük ortak
noktası istikrarlı bir şekilde çalışmak
beni 10 kişide biliyorken 20 kişide
biliyorken ben bu yaptığım çalışmalara
inandığım için insanların yüzündeki
tebessüme inandığım için bu çalışmaların
istikrarlı bir şekilde Yaptım Yaptım
Yaptım yayınladım insanlarla buluşturdum
ve bir nokta geldi
çalışmalarım binlerce kişi tarafından
paylaşılmaya başlandı her illüstratör
her tasarımcı için en önemli şey bu
yaptığı çalışmanın mümkün olduğunca
fazla kişiye ulaşması
ve bir nokta geldik çok büyük markalarla
çok büyük projeler yapmaya başladık
bu yaptım şansını oyun oynamak gibi
bulmaca çözmek gibi
[Müzik]
bu ist çalışmalar sonucunda hedefine
adım adım ulaşırken
size verebileceğim en büyük tavsiye
gerçekten inandığınız bir fikriniz bir
projeniz varsa bunu mümkün olduğunca
insanlarla paylaşmaya çalıştım çünkü
yayınladığımız bir şey Dünyanın bir
ucundan başka birisi görebiliyor O
nedenle
başlarda belki değer görmeyi bilir çok
fazla kişi yaptığınız Fikri görmeyi
görmeyebilir
bir şekilde bu çalışmalarınızı devam
ederseniz yayınlarsanız belli bir
noktaya geldikten sonra
çalışmalarınızda işimiz
neden istikrarlı bir şekilde çalışarak
umutsuzluğa kapılmadan işlerinizi
üretmeyi tavsiye beni dinlediğiniz için
çok teşekkür ederim
[Alkış]